let me ask you this when you were an
intern and
you i know that you were very young when
you interned for us you were like yeah
19 years old i think i was 19. yeah um
you at the time must have been
interested in comedy
sometimes you know it's hard for interns
because they're
they're told you got to be professional
you can't approach that's right
famous people were you giving that whole
spiel
they gave me the whole speech at the
beginning don't talk to famous people
don't talk to the guests
but then uh jonathan katz came on the
show one time and he was from
uh from uh dr katz professional
therapist hilarious
hilarious comedian one of them one of
the great tv series
of uh comedy nerds like me and he lived
and worked in boston and my brother joe
who had interned on your show as well
was living in boston was an aspiring
comedy writer and so i was
and so i was like i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna introduce
john katz to my brother joe so i
i completely cross a line and i just
follow i get out of the control room i
spot him after he walks off stage
and i follow jonathan katz and i'm like
i'm going to talk to jonathan katz
he makes a right turn into the bathroom
and i had that
fork in the road moment where you go
should i follow
a celebrity comedian into a public
restroom and the answer conan is yes
i went
i waited until he was washing his hands
and then i said
jonathan i'm mike for bigly i work on
the show i didn't say i was an intern
but i was wearing a nice shirt and i and
i looked 50 when i was 20. so i had a
high
my hairline you know my hairline was
this since i was 13.
basically and and you could have been a
producer for all he knew
i could have been produced right i got
my brother joe's aspiring comedy writer
in boston can i put him in touch with
you he goes oh yeah he's soft-spoken guy
he goes
oh yeah absolutely he goes um let me
just write my number down do you have
anything that i could
you know write it in and i was just like
oh well these paper towels i think
could uh we could write it on and so
then i uh
you know we took out a paper towel he
wrote down his number put him in touch
with joe and joe worked for him for
several days
and uh yeah so i i overstepped and uh
and actually if i i don't know if this
is inappropriate i know this is your
talk show
uh i don't know if this is the time or
the place but i was uh
my brother joe is uh trying to figure
out his life right now he was an intern
for you 20 years ago
and i was wondering if you would take a
meeting with him
if i could give him your number uh well
it's it's on the line to ask me on the
air it's it's
no wait joe's here now
no that's my brother that's my brother
joe this is inappropriate
it's one thing for you and i to talk off
the air and for me to give you my number
to have joe appear on the show is way
over the line
joe it's over the line this is wrong
i'll show myself out no no joe please
stay how are you joe
where are you i'm well i'm in rhode
island also my home you both are in
rhode island
yes okay uh where and this is near
providence
yes right outside of providence okay big
snowstorm coming down huh
it's coming down right now okay all
right let me tell you my rhode island
story okay now that you're here
and yes i'll do anything i can for you
but
i'll say to you is this though joe i
will help you in any way i can
your brother has four cameras i have one
i think you're talking to the wrong guy
you ready for my rhode island story
please my grandfather uh had a little
cottage
down in rhode island we didn't have a
summer place when i was growing up so we
would go and we would visit my
grandfather
in the town uh there's a fancy town
nearby called watch hill
there was this big mansion on a hill so
many many years later i'm walking
through that town
and i buy there's a nice painting of
that mansion
on a hill that looks out at the sea in
rhode island i buy it
and i'm like this is cool this reminds
me of my youth my grandfather
hanging out with my brothers and sisters
going to the state beach this is really
cool and i put it up on my wall
lo and behold about five years after i
do that taylor swift buys that mansion
completely redoes it and it becomes
taylor swift's like graceland
literally there's like musical notes on
the gate um
you know it's this big thing people hang
around out front to try and see taylor
swift
yeah i have that painting and i put it
in our guest room here in my house in
los angeles
so these people come to stay with me and
i'm showing them the guest room
and they say what's that a painting of
and i went that's my painting of taylor
swift's house
and everyone's like you're a [ __ ]
freak
you're you're a creep you're a creep and
i'm i didn't explain
that i had it long it's like i had a
painting made of her home
and i'm going to marry her someday
because i love taylor swift and i'll be
mr swift
that's my story i just wanted you to
appreciate my rhode island roots
joe had one story that i thought was
really funny about being an intern i go
do you have a memory of being a ninja on
the show
you were an intern for us what do you
remember i i was and one of the the
honors of being the intern was that you
would
once a week it would be your job to
order in dinner for conan andy richter
and the writers and
throw their they you know write their
initials
joe you know this is conan right i know
that
i know it's been a long time since joe
a worked for me or b watched the show so
he right now i think he thinks he's
talking to a very pleasant middle-aged
irish woman
so so so
the question was when i was ordering the
dinner because i'm you know i'm 20 years
old at the time and you're it's
stressful working television for the
first
time like that and it's the question was
can i put conan's co initials on his
dinner
or would is someone trying to kill him
perhaps
guess what i love them guess what there
were people out to kill me
then and actually they worked on the
same network as me
so yeah one of them one of them was jay
leno
i know it's good yeah which one is his
with uh which one is conan eating wait
can i just borrow it for a second
yeah there you go yeah take care of that
little
right now
you